your doctor may perform a percutaneous
endoscopic gastrostomy or P eg to insert
a feeding tube into your stomach if you
were unable to take food by mouth for an
extended period of time
digestion of food begins in the mouth
when you swallow food is pushed down
into your esophagus a muscular tube that
carries food to your stomach where it is
digested
from the stomach food travels to your
small intestine where digestion
continues and nutrients are absorbed
into the bloodstream
your doctor may require a P eg feeding
tube
if you cannot eat digest or absorb food
due to esophageal cancer oral surgery or
stroke major surgery trauma burns or
anorexia inflammation of the pancreas or
radiation therapy or inflammatory bowel
disease affecting the small intestine
before the procedure you'll receive a
sedative through an IV to help you relax
a local anaesthetic will be administered
at the site on your abdomen where the PG
tube is to be placed the most commonly
used P eg placement procedure is the
pull method during this procedure your
doctor will insert a lighted endoscopes
through your mouth and thread it down
your esophagus and into your stomach a
camera attached to the endoscope will
produce images of the inside of your
stomach which will be displayed on a
video monitor next your doctor will
insert a needle through your skin into
your stomach at the location where the P
eg tube is to be placed while doing this
he or she will use the endoscope to
locate the end of the needle inside your
stomach and encircle it with a wire
snare your doctor will then pass a thin
wire through this needle into your
stomach attach the endoscope to the wire
and pull both the endoscope and wire out
through your mouth at this point there
will be a thin wire entering the front
of your abdomen into your stomach and
continuing upward and out of your mouth
your doctor will attach the P eg feeding
tube to the wire outside of your mouth
by gently tugging on the other end of
the wire he or she will pull the tube
back through your mouth and esophagus
and into your stomach your doctor will
continue to pull until the tip of the
tube comes out of the incisions in your
stomach and abdomen a soft round bumper
attached to the portion of the tube that
remains inside the stomach secures it in
place the outer portion of the tube will
be
cured with a bumper as well and sterile
gauze will be placed around the incision
site
and the alternative push method your
doctor will begin in the same fashion by
using an endoscope to guide a wire
through your abdominal wall and into
your stomach but instead of pulling the
PE g-tube through your mouth he or she
will push it directly into your stomach
over the wire after your procedure you
will continue to receive fluids through
an IV for one to two days once there is
evidence that your digestive tract is
functioning you will receive clear
liquids through the PE G tube if clear
liquids are tolerated you will receive a
tube feeding formula through the PE G
tube